lead the rush over the line it goes kolie is
in [__] Stars Logan [__] in a beauty first
in the National Hockey League for 92 got to
go they had a man Advantage here got to gois
now turns it into a two-on-one with Terry a
some mavage to Terry score hatrick overtime
game winner Beautiful Finish from him a minute
left in the power play for the Rangers here up
from the score Chris krider on a beautiful setup
from our T paner it's a two-on-one Chatfield goes
down he gets beat five hole that's as good of a
passer as there is in the game yes sir dumps one
ahead hoping Miller can get there first he does
he scores what a play by Brock besser to angle
that one off the cornerboards Miller there puts
it home in the back hand and the Canucks have a
two nothing lead here's Pon at the offensive blue
line couchs across feed Susi face pass mcav scores
Carson Susi put it on the tape and Ilia mcav
makes it 5 nothing Vancouver an odd man Rush
turns it into the fifth goal of the hockey game
for the Canucks look this L had a great training
camp here's Mar scores Mitch M Far Side along
the ice and the Maple Leafs are on the board
clearing pass fails but Branson into the slot
left wing scores tick tac toe and the Russian
three and the Blue Jackets finally see a goal
from marchenko it's one to nothing quick outl
and up the ice comes aot aot up the Middle St
what a goal by Mikey aimont what an outstanding
second effort for aimont here quick turn to the
board barzel opens up doson doson cruising back
SC Noah doson and four on four on the helper from
M barel Crosby stepping ahead of the pack drops
it for lank backhander score absolutely sick from
the Pittsburgh Penguins Chris lanks got his first
of the year sandine on the go tried to split
the Defenders Wilson there to help his dries go
that puck was bouncing all over the place Wilson
stick handled it once on a hop and shot it off
the Hop to get Washington un tront ptra closes
and wow what a goal scorer's move right there
the poison the confidence in the finish by Matt
ptra going off the back of the boot either good
play by Thompson he's going to have a partial
Breakaway Thompson takes the shot scores saved
at first but Thompson stuck with it down by one
as the Savers with a short-handed goal that's his
second short-handed goal of the Year almost every
back comes forb trying to answer WRA around score
Philip forsberg he faked Campbell out of his
skates and wrapped it in to tie the game at one
eel walking in shot score in and out of the back
of the net just like that for Jack eel with eel's
third and two nights have a two nothing lead molo
rer knocked down in front Reinhard and bar goore
Sasha marov in front the cats are on fire they've
got three early this was in the building Elvis
is now leaving the building causing a commotion
in front ni tied up Matthews gets it the Marner
sliding it through this scor mat KN with the big
guys the score sheet first quick hands in front
to knock it down and get it up and over Johansson
Marner trying to Spring knce here's n in Matthews
scores it's a one goal game and it's number 13
stay to Def get up on your feet ball back in has
walstrom he Tri the SC what a play for Oliver
walstrom the Islanders have their first lead of
the night now rmus dolene at Center makes one move
gains the line off the boards to himself takes a
shot scores Rasmus doing with some doll Magic on
that play ties the game on the power play as bka
tries to work around traffic he's knocked to the
ice no arms going up at this point oh front score
it's Alex tuck right in front of the net that
puck finds him at 89 buries it to tie the game
of one with 1609 remaining in the second period
back pass up head to aimos and aim battles and
gets it towards the end here he comes sharp angle
shot scores he got it up and over the shoulder of
Jake Allen what a shot by Mikey acon go he's on
it they got a penalty H BR Nick Robson back pass
that landsly right over the leg and over the
glove Alexius to win a battle bring it ahead
short handed McMichael he scores cus at mcel a
short-handed tally to TI fourth overtime game for
the capitals it's the third and here's a chance
for Parov right in and he scores it's Reinhardt
the winner just 15 seconds into overtime just an
outstanding play by Reinhardt after a great pass
by barov forg busts in drags and holds he shoots
scor Ry providing the traffic late but forsberg
able to deal it all the way to the slot to tie
it up pass ahead and on the left side with speed
it's Kyle Conor off the wing caught it right out
front scores what a goal by Kyle Conor and it's
3-1 Jets back into the hands of Cole stolen by
Bon sett for his scor and that beauty of a goal
as ascends on the board as sends have life with
just under two minutes left in the first period
hands it off to Crosby looking in front they
score the magic once again Crosby gel back
of the net of beauty puts the pens in front nice
drop pass Russ will try again comes behind and it
wrap around go are you kidding me take that one to
the B Brian Rush from the Penguins top the Kings
43 and OT Matthews throw out ahead knocked down
BR pu goes to neander warning and scores what a
move by William neander a power play goal it's one
nothing Toronto and the streak goes on back around
the knee Lander Cent to Wi a pass TOA scores oh my
goodness what a pass for the goal he cled himself
into a pretzel got hammered and then put it right
on a platter for John sarus finding it his tippet
moves around vrono in a go he scor oh and Tipp
dazzles on his way in what a move on vrono he puts
it behind him takes it to his forehand he's got a
lot of Nets to work with and what a finish sanheim
in sanheim Cuts in the back in he's gone Davis
sanheim spectacular goal Michael able to slip the
check of Addison has Carlson in front score what
a set up William Carlson short handed from Jacko
it's nothing B here's a chance for Skinner now
catching up to the puck on a break boy Skinner de
scor Skinner turns on the Jets and go all the
way to give the Savers a two to one lead with
58 seconds remaining in the second period
[Applause] taken here by Raymond stop score
what a beautiful play look as Raymond gets
set for sweeten and finally for the first
time in eight games the Red Wings have scored
the first goal great one timer over the head
is put in and Denny with some absolute sorcery
from the corner are you kidding me carcone has
it SC unbelievable s carone's got two and the
coyotes have the lead now he's got a breakway
for the hatrick b davage in and he scores the hat
trick for B davit two hat tricks tonight and the
hats are flying in Denver shot now the re two
goals in 27 seconds and Montreal's taking the
lead and now sod raises in to the net now back
in front they score and the blows up taken a
two nothing lead as shenna scored again what an
effort there by Brandon s Bard takes the puck
scores what a goal by Conor Bard what a steal
far down unbelievable by Conor Bard distance on
flb and what a beautiful stretch here's McDavid
off the re Tri go home so broken be and mcdavis
gets one to go in picked up by cadri cadri in
with a power move to the slaughter the scores
Calgary great move off the boards whips it home
makes it one nothing Calgary that is so hard
to do spinning and then just elevates over the
right pad duaine Springs it San has a step San
scores Tyler Sean tie
game poock scor cross ice pass from zaka and
the Bruins strike twice here's Carlson a shot
deflected in the PED goal Sydney Crosby goes
upstairs absolute Magic from the captain and
the pens go in front set aeit here comes
kimy R busting through shoot and St Jo out
Kim on top he split the D he fires it right
through the body of doall for his first goal
as a Colorado Avalanche pin in shot denied by SK
the rebound they score Alexander wiberg with his
first goal of the Season cheuck TI out head for
stla winding in is Tim stla L The Edge feeds it
back and Chuck scores what a feed by stla and
kachuck got his second there's a pass and a
half right onto the tape of kachuck Jon drops it
back think comes back the pass ACR the SC he BS
it in t with an incredible hand play Oh What
a goal here's Russ racing back in backhander
scor well he's not stopping that one Brian
rust upstairs and the Pens have the first
goal once again Cory Perry he's got some help
try to swing it across in front SLE that Tick
Tac to oh and it's Cory Perry who finishes off
a brilliant Chicago setup chips it to Center
try to break it he's got space yes he olol it
to the four half score what a goal second of
the season for yesie UL top shelf off the
turnover and the half's up 31 goodus got a
stick on it now lerina picks it up again moina
out in front he scores and two has his first
of the season of the Panthers are on top first
career penalty shot for sprong and it's a goal
Daniel wow Red Wings lead it one to nothing
P Maro out top Theodor down low backand Maro
scores on a spin move for Jonathan maraso puts
it home in the backand and the golden knights
from two goals down to a tie game as AO comes
up with an intercept drop this one back Jarvis
Teri and AO they score t Tech tied Carolina
Sebastian AO buries it his fifth of the year
of walstrom and now it's posil with a in a
roll posil in scores a beauty by and it's
the coov swirls back here's hman Hedman hangs
on KRA back and forth across s go SC and the
the lightning strike again on the power play it's
tie game the batt to paner cross I tro now Guston
tro try to get it through paner scores but Timmy
panan it's a power play goal here's VC TR it off
save Jimmy VC with his second of the game and
the Rangers lead it 4 to three short-handed
bre Kee in DS score sweet hands from Adrien Kee a
short-handed goal three nothing La Marchman he'll
flip it in front caught nicely just score what
a Play Tyler San out of mid air had the angle
for side shelf to get the stars on the board
and the beat goes on for number 91 now it's
neander the other way he's got toar with him
Ines neander tries up scores William neander
puts an exclamation point and a brilliant
week in Stockholm Eric Johnson racing after
the aention getting around Seth Jones scores Eric
Johnson with some magic for the Sabers and gives
Buffalo the lead at 3-2 with 924 remaining in the
third forced back Bard to drive SLE one Tim score
M DAV from the spot where drle usually buries it
now he gets it back to Hughes lots of traffic in
front as Quinn Hughes cuts across the high slot
now goes wide on zerland Hughes shoots he score
Poston in and he ties his career high with his
eighth of the Season Canucks open the scoring
Quinn Hughes doesn't need much room and it's in
the net man he's the Magician on his feet knock
Saka a turnover leaks to the ti goal pav zaka
heel to CRA what a finish here 7 Seconds stand it
across oh they score they've tied the game Steven
St Coast with 4 seconds to go short-handed here's
Den know for more streaking to the right Circle a
shot he scores another short-handed goal for the
Kings Trevor Moore coyotes turn it over Byfield
to his backand feeds it across score on J kopar
on another great setup by Quinton Byfield two
nothing Kings took that pass away Sabers get it
back again here's Benson in front what a move
scores Zack Benson with his first NHL goal and
that is a beauty to remember for all time wow
what a goal by Zack Benson and puts the Savers
up two to nothing the blues get it back and a
feet ahead and he he's got to breakway in the
CLA Hayes scores Kevin Hayes and the blows have
taken a six to five lead what a goal L gets it
back heals to B Tilly returned and L has the goal
what a play by P Tilly to throw it right across
the go bow it's 71 into the Dallas H treela fell
down eel has the puck try to move it lost to gets
it back eel scores Jack gel stayed with it and
wins it in overtime McDavid won a battle from
behind the net cleed home and there it is zck
hman has cut to 53 his second of the night and
it's game on and rally Bruins charge ahe three on
two into the Zone Co dances in back and scores an
impressive indivisual effort from Charlie Coy the
Bruins have the first goal tonight but Toronto on
it sneaks around the defender Frank to the front
of the neet great pass M he scores what a great
individual effort by Frank patrono Mavis with
the Finish Frank patrono is just all hustle BL
wheeler score oh is that a beauty wheeler to
zban Jed for the second time of the game it's
three nothing rers lead with in the Box Here
Comes G trying to pick his way in G back for
stos St stos makes it four straight
games with a goal power play goal number
199 P here's Robertson left wing Circle his shot
he scores he found a window over the shoulder of
markr Jason Robertson On The Board gets the tally
here on home ice and Dallas goes back and front
cherry on the way backin goes for the net there's
the pass scor Zer with a terrific pass to backin
who puts it ho what a set up a set up at both
ends and out of the Zone it goes yes pulled
ahead Byers oneon-one Nikolai eers KS a throw gets
around and he shoots and scores what a goal from
Nikolai eers and it's two nothing Winnipeg he's
got his danc and shoes on tonight Dan charks have
had the lead twice here's grin in alone he scores
what a goal by m KY grin his first as a Shar and
it's a beauty here's aari off the turnover R
shot scores no achari goes upstairs he got a
cookie for TI Here Comes Ryan Johansson he'll
race in after a loose p and a opportunity of
the refere around he scores Ryan Johanson and the
have a two nothing lead neighbors gets the loose
Puck he's in the clar shoots he scores ho he jump
and what a goal by Jake neers and the blues lead
one nothing that he's got that goal scorer ability
along with that tenacity and boy did we see it on
display to Raymond top of the right Circle pulls
it back nice play across scores pan by David pan
has been rejuvenated the last couple of weeks
he was in the shooting position and boy did he
release that quickly sting SS the base off back to
darn elur a bullet down the middle break away new
jkin he scores 32 Edon with its first lead and the
Oilers have gotten to do all for three goals on
four shots I high takes it from marchenko with a
shot save all rebound scores yes a power play goal
through marenco and it's 4 nothing Columbus after
practice we going scratch every right oh what a
a play there's the first of the year for JG Paso
as the Islanders have opened it up to a 4-2 lead
this will lead to a breakway Conor McDavid in on
Thompson back air score the captain makes it three
to2 McDavid stays hot his eight blocked up front
by broin he's able to Spring Baldi M Baldi in he
scores quick little snapshot plenty of flex
on that stick flick of the wrist up over the
glove of Winnington Here Comes COV back over the
boards trying to chip that around give go COV to
the net across scores coov to bladed point and
the lightning are on the board up for the air
save BYO easy store got a stick on it I think it's
good Jody it's below the crossbar and what a goal
for the Rangers what a finish for VC Bobby P had
a goal last night nice move there P right in a
go oh he scores what a play Robbie fabry red hot
it's two to1 Detroit ji he's going for the empty
net bouncing towards the goal he scores you have
witnessed history Tristan jari becomes the first
goenda goal it's the drop pass Middleton holds on
drives it he scores Minnesota on the rush had the
delayed penalty the extra attacker was trailing
in all kinds of numbers for the Wild and they
connected for a second time protecting against
any Rush chances luno got it to Lea got to the
front of the and scores head his back to the net
and has his first of the year it's a one goal game
UT wiggle and Saka scores aox ability to freeze
Defenders is paralyzing Hol off the turnover he's
dangerous has two short-handed goals and he hits
the crossbar and in Simon Holstrom shorthanded and
that will tie him with Logan o' Conor for the NHL
lead Calgary for 13 years then with the blues for
10 here's a quick jot scores Benson right off
the face off rips it low and pass binnington